2 millions d'armes ne seraient pas
déclarées en France jusqu'au 2 décembre
le ministère de l'Intérieur organise
dans chaque département une opération
d'abandon simplifiée d'armes à l'état
c'est le cas en Indre-et-Loire mais
aussi en Loir-et-Cher ou deux armes
drôles ont été ouverts une semaine pour
laisser Césars ou pour les déclarer dès
le premier jour la moisson s'avère
plutôt bonne comme vous allez le voir
dans ce reportage de Florent Clavel à
Pezou près de Vendôme
dans la mallette de ce chasseur une arme
qui appartenait à son père s'il est venu
à la gendarmerie de Pezou ce matin c'est
pour la déclarer
jusqu'en 83 ou 4 et je souhaiterait la
conserver je la garde en souvenir comme
lui ils sont déjà une quinzaine de
loir-et-chariens en deux heures à peine
à s'être déplacé pour profiter de
l'opération lancé par l'État jusqu'au 2
décembre les particuliers peuvent
déclarer ou abandonner une arme sans
craindre de poursuite judiciaire
c'est très important de participer à
cette opération nationale d'abord pour
assurer la sécurité de nos concitoyens
la deuxième raison c'est naturellement
pour limiter les risques de diffusion de
ces armes dans le cadre de trafic la
majorité des armes ramenées aujourd'hui
provient d'héritage devenu un peu trop
encombrant que je me trompe pas un
pistolet pas un revolver un pistolet il
vient de mon beau beau-père et je l'ai
ramené parce que j'ai peur lors d'un vol
qui soit
qui soit parti et que quelqu'un commette
un acte délictueux avec une fois
abandonnée par son propriétaire les
gendarmes vérifient que l'arme n'est pas
chargée grâce à un tube à sable avant de
l'enregistrer dans leur fichier 33 933
calibre quand elles arrivent nous on les
passe aussi ce qu'on appelle au fauves
c'est à dire que ça nous permet de
savoir si c'est pas une arme qui aurait
pu servir à commettre un crime ou un
délit mais surtout le but principal
c'est de retirer de de la circulation
toutes ces armes qui qui servent à rien
en fait on estime à 2 millions en France
le nombre d'armes non déclarées celle-ci
comme les autres sera détruite